deftly hour of sixty january thirty one
nineteen eighty five
and we're looking at losses chasing too
losses occupied by the federal bureau of
investigation san antonio texas
the purpose of the really important
joseph lyrically perfect little stuart
refresh his memory
pollutants that he may have witnessed
associated with an undercover reverse
operation in miami lakes florida or off
eleven nineteen eighty four
in addition to his salt
james to the jenny
especially to the federal bureau of
investigation
d_e_a_ specially generator furthers
presidents
for gerardo caesar's c_n_n_ senior
inspectors
drug enforcement ministration
headquarters
cdc
and doctors who treat you are required
practices
texas
do you understand why you are here
with the purpose of these
etcetera
english team
your personal situation
has to talk
interview such as your foot in front of
alter
uni
objection was videotaping
people not at all
do you have any
objection if any of the people of the
present
if you do it
please let's go
obviously reject
it's not real prompt
well basically what we're doing
and just work not comfortable talking
works alaska
at a
its people
spy operation
if you agree
transformer right
it's not like to give just flew back to
the neglect murder
he's a certified licensed clinical
psychologist in private practice in san
antonio texas
he's involved the treatment of several
hundred patients each move from the
train many doctors therapy
he's a typically american board of
psychological perot systems especially
in clinical sources
answers as a special let's hope to be a
the questions
no mannitol
roared head just a moment to may deny
and stuff
carryover
here to do
in terms of uh... how we're going to use
hypnosis
hypnosis is an altered state of
consciousness so
sonawane invasive procedure
but the way it's going to be used for
years
clearly is uh... more relaxation
focused than anything else
um...
hollow
jackie gleason
tests answering questions you have
meant exactly how we're going to use and
in here
uh...
some people think of hypnosis is
asleep states
uh... it's really not be she is
different
sleep in
uh... actually it's going to be in this
situation more like heaven bakery
you're going to be aware uh...
being relaxed and being here
be aware
of staying sporadic
a person who would be heading hypnosis
for surgery was not we would ask him
did so see we've asked
go fishing
how do you know where they wanted to go
out and we can see that they get there
they wouldn't be here
and obviously that would be counter to
what we're
want to do here
this is to enhance
and hypnosis
has ah...
as it's another a focus
uh... now the focus surgery patient
kind of the same focuses
your i would have we listened to a
boring speaker would be the speaker
would be away some
we hope that this will be the same kind
of focus that uh...
or woman would have won
first and a child with hypnosis uh...
she doesn't want to be away she wants to
be a part of that she's hypnotized to
produce anesthesia which is very much
involved here
uh... if we were listening
very interesting charismatic speaker
we would be very much involved here
to the exclusion brothers thanks
where the focus will be
it will be here
part of you
um...
focusing on our
questions
and you also
uh...
then be someone else were asking you to
go
to the situation
i called up memory block just back
visualize
this other places other times where you
have
certainly then
and uh... place yourself there
and then go with
abs
forward from there is that were happy
now
uh... go forward
uh... through that period of time
s you know we can do to slowly carefully
we can come to stop the action
and have you going that far and answer
some questions taken
and uh... it will
as i understand that it will be
at a time
that uh... up
were anymore
involved with the actions you will of
the
simply the in
tell us what you're doing
as you go through it again in your mind
uh... the reason
the excused him well in a moment
to consciously
used to see
uh...
uh... what the difference against
between your conscience recollect
recollection would which is a course
being here
and the president and trying to remember
back
as to what happened
as opposed to uh...
getting relaxed and then going back
there and bill
for or against the law
what seems
to elicit
better recall that
basically that's it
that's what we do that
comparison heavy tel
mister kenney consciously which remember
than we do the hypnotic
so let's see it nutshell
i guess i mean only to blow up
how much alaska now before we do the
actual
hypnotic u
formally if you want any medication
roar
okay and that
do you have any other medical history
media karenga unconsciousness
trouble with anesthesia
and any psychiatric history
thank you well know well i guess one of
them
and how is your vision normally subtotal
twenty nor
so it's not twenty twenty twenty twenty
uh... quicktime i'm afraid i have about
two point six
summer courses for distance i do occur
request but i don't recall
because uh... okay at the time of this
uh... particular situation where you
wearing glasses or was it
purchased uh... starter work
exact murder or your
from the last year
and are you
tuna which uh...
colorblind do you have
separate blues and yellows reds and
dreams
reno's recent tested for them
six months corrected
any questions for me
i would like to do is really concerned
let me ask you to look at
fast-track
january thirty one nineteen eighty five
percent twenty six ext
high court and joseph brennan hereby
agreed voluntarily unfriendly to undergo
hypnosis indian of yogurt
an order to assist program
ministration yeti
with continue
or investigation
media is conducting
finished and change the buchanan a
special agent via
will be present
the system here
understand that the other tape
recordings made in the entire interview
this method preservation of the
interview may be used for any lawful
purpose to make with this investigation
or any subsequent action based upon the
investigation
doctor richard b garber
health professional
as explained procedures to be used
during the course includes ghosts
and any questions i had concerns
procedure to have been injured much
satisfaction
purpose of this interview under hypnosis
used to assist my memory recalling of
those when they have witnessed
associated with an undercover reversed
operation
miami lakes florida form
march eleventh nineteen anymore
let me ask you what
feel like you understand
doctor burk
richest
like to see the tape record time
process
towards us
as it pertains to this
insists this operation
right back
prior to march you ever thought that was
it
probably the night
i was down there from savannah system
here simply operation grouper
separate
nation charges about that
that we had a young
another river still go down the et
cetera occasionally the apartment with
no
involving flashing
it a fifty thousand thirty keys cook
i got involved in the chain of custody
of the coke
it was
bothersome to me that the uh...
the methods of controlling use for the
evidence
not up to my standards
using its bases that
sometime require before they went down
on you know by the fact that was that
morning
we had a radio
how the deal was going to go
as i said that uh...
i was insistent that we were going to
have
some color
using i don't want to be evidence labels
insecure
the more that was anticipated to be
obtained from the uh... violators
seal that in some matter admit
but special but when you get involved
with it
and that way i would have to
be involved the chain of custody of the
evidence
core case of a basically the groups in
miami
and that my participation of operating a
sealed box
i could hold it for a period of time
interna back program still not appear in
me
personal training custody because of the
uh...
my confidence in the ceiling method
just uh...
i would have to be a personal
involvement chatting testing
solo at some time with the meeting in
the morning insisted that
we do use
part of the day to get labels evidence
labels
and put it in the box and somehow we got
the xerox box
they've been
are we all went out to the undercover
area
video
first thing they uh... group supervisor
surprise may twenty change implanted
you've been on the outside situation
which is a surveillance and the rest of
back i definitely department cook
because i've
urls or
there was a supervisor at all it was her
from out of town in that
russia dot i've heard that job it's his
group in his operation
but i agreed to do it anyway
we get set up on your part of the top
miami lakes
uh... deal was that the other coverage
in srini apartment
address we have done in the past
hedberg i screw up to the seven-eleven
area
call the house another coverage would
come out
repairman lead them into the area as
protective
meantime
we had the preliminary surveillance up
seven eleven
determined that they had received a call
webster beijing he would come up to me
trans a m me but the two subjects
i think ran a super bowl
station wagon
and drive towards a house
let's agree on something fun and we had
set up on the house
i set up in a position that
looking down they'd
dead-end or call the sack driveway at
birth and i think bout five apartments
on either side
where i could see sidewalk
entrance to the house which is recessed
back
off the sidewalk wards
uh... we have previously arranged that
uh... it's a deal went down bad guys got
the coke
that the uh... agent healy would come
out to the car with the paragraph visual
signaled that
deal gone down
that we would put the arrest planned an
operation
but also planned that
uh... after securing the bad guys which
was to take place
although swing within sight of the
undercover apartment
keep big eyes younger cover partner cool
we would
fake hitting the apartment kicking out
the door allege william
arresting them
to make bad guys like that
they worked out
pickups
we set up a department as i said i was
sitting right over
g_m_c_ blazer
fishburne triple dot
i was sitting in with a female agent
from
sergeant deputy sheriff from some rural
county near panama city florida
singer was very excited about what's
called a secondary character reporting
we had uh... dade county
marking it
both ends of it with agents following
number with them
coke was not in the house and the bad
guys right
they made another phone call
and judge juncture rot
drove up in his z car
parker and took broke into the house
worked with cooked tore the house
disturbance at his car which was
crossed the drive from
department
eventually uh...
patio in the tube there guys came out
put something in the car since she was
with them i know that uh...
they had the cocoa word of the uh...
under surveillance unit soon as they
came up in
turned down the street outside of the
press department
dade county public safety and moved in
from the front
super stop 'n i started to back up
and the other parking and came up behind
them
the agents in the car behind
the dade county united front
came at the car
for this time i had
come over the wall
retaining wall between driveway where i
was more the action was
media
progress without reference to your time
both guys had guns
we seize them
i'm a cook
withstand a confusion for example
molecules
and then
as an afterthought sort of polio what's
at the apartment
jeff got there had to me
because he was a really involved in the
bust
and nobody
made a lot more reasons than for white
sherri automatic out says okay let's go
to department ran down there
short distance to attend
who got a caller makes a lot how it
looked like a pocketful
that idea
put up a bit on the door
and women
inside the agents i remember that were
in their words
ted we need
larry on
pattie lee
and i think door driven from panama city
someway i got the money
and that's been the
urge somebody said there is
box of money
that money is in the box
and they were
that evidence tapes for on it
and some of the also suggested hurry up
twists
clean up the place because we expect
another
but repair guys and they're going to run
some ordeal again
as i picked up the box
the evidence tapes
kmart
not to put up a pop up the bottom
and uh...
summer session elegant chain of custody
money
i took it back out
took custody of the money
unanimously elect or going back to my
blazer
over back over the fence print
my memory progress previously that
jeff and i got in this physique are and
wrote down to the gas station
or semester brought surgeons were and
whoever had driven by blazer down there
but the money in the back of the blazer
solstice female weijin
there was a black agent of the company
spectrum
did you get your office
character money upstairs
group form a group of working with
then an agent from savannah that work
for me and to
local police officers from maine
i'm going to go to church berkeley
county police department georgia who
where with me
par boiled to raj
calendar money quickly recounted bottles
i don't recall which
an intermittent started to her quarter
resort about a hundred and sixty five
thousand dollars there
temporarily sealed the
put the money back in a box temporarily
sealed it again
directed in
plastic tape and put my evidence
stickers on it but my sb a matter of
time
and stored it in seoul
cus was two days later
but check it out process the money
cabinet
again and again
verified account on it
and put it into your evidence envelopes
clear evidence envelopes
and he'll heat seal dot
turned in the cashier
are not the trial
brixton made about the fact that the
money was not what was supposed to pay
riots and sorry were american trial
that the defense attorney
had already given his defendants power
grab his client
the defendant
polygraph tests and they had
pestered her indicated that they had not
taking a minute there was two hundred
for twenty thousand or something like
that they're
and their personal or indeed you must be
responsible for it
loss of it
i took polygraph
are desperate but i don't have anything
to it
without going into details are going up
questions that's what i don't
specifically what would
that was important
and let me ask you this reporter
their efforts to be quite honestly
we don't know
what aspect please
espn suture roadmap
confirm any of the person talking to you
this person
to cut it started
i think for purposes
he said it was a meeting
pure before they went out i was reading
a preacher of strep
that morning as opposed to pay before
will use
that week
has a point
we would go to okay
it
than speed
stitching struck
touch with
the academic
pukekohe
sarcastic is
creature with a smile
what date it was like a great
parts that
today at the eleventh
analytically
so conversations
how you end up
of the state return basically field
if at any time
on talking to
investigator your kids
logical
and while i'm gone
three to four
the force unleashed
too slow for me at all
but it's an exclusive sculptor
each starting tomorrow
that i feel that
and if you don't like the end of the
question
ustrust com
version of the engineer
tears and while i don't know i didn't
say we have four or for the march eleven
so we want to go to the meeting before
march eleventh
scenario
march eleventh th morning or
were
engaged me
discussion
refusing interested in that meeting
really
so it's just blocks
any discussion clark's house
tree i really think that would be
treating him too
with group one one speech ep fraternity
uh... pat
transcript ready for that
they do that
business because no i did not not yet
federal murder statute com politically
so it's a guerilla army reporters
just like a cat problems
about all
azide
as i mentioned to you before
uh...
were both during our talked with you
help control act
and uh...
and help you
go through this
and uh...
basically if you were going through this
uh...
probably
as you were thinking about these events
do even had mental pictures that
formed in your mind
responses to
recounting
basically that's uh... what we're going
to be doing
except that uh... might like to start by
just to
closing ron's
relaxing
just being his company
and uh...
under
that would be uh...
taking your
pollster kidney stone have this
so i can
have some
idea of how you're doing
and if you just take uh... a deep breath
for me now slovene c_n_n_ let it all out
another one
this one on the ice tea grant hold on
okay jordan now
feel the tension built
and use that
as a signals to police
upto
not all tension ran away
what i'd like you do
is
to begin in just two
tobacco way that'll help you do that
mr starr one
think silently to yourself backward by
law
and continue to do
just uh...
give me a signaled by lieutenant
spangler adjective
nine times account was different
marxist helps you concentrate
consciously
your unconscious mind
and it just happens very natural
are you doing that now
i want you also that just kind of
drift back
and time
earlier
eighty-four last last month
it really doesn't matter
what defense you touch
uh... during this course
but the target
march eleven
nineteen eighty one
at that meeting
which is
discuss
and i just want you to kind of take your
time
and drift back to that time and when you
when you get there and
what you've just
place yourself at that meeting
so that we can go forward from
and when you do that
you can stop the counting
you can't just
let me know
by uh... oh
just racing
another signal that we can't use
there's a part of your brain your
unconscious by that helps relax even
i'm just going to give you a signal that
signal is just
uh... pressure on your right shoulder
just like this
pressure will be a signal
for you to relax
even more become more involved in
in the in the jury
and when you can get a picture
of you
at that
before it starts her just as it starting
you could pick spot you know best work
began
venue signalman
and mr kenny and i
will
help you get more involved
actually uh...
we're going to be going along for the
ride so to speak and having you
sort of the art
eyes that are here's archived
bullets you
help us
needs you to tell us where we're going
wannabe their with yelling
so it'll be some pictures that are
occurring to us as you explain your
stuffs
what you're seeing
to be now
when that time becomes now
wants you to
go through that
tell us what you're doing now
what you're going to do next
and you will
will be attempting to stay with you
to form pictures in our minds as well
what has happened
how you describe it
kept us
and i suggest to you
as you warned this method as you go
along
that uh...
that you'll be able to use this yourself
to relax and
uh...
handle world
stress